there's this uh cable news channel
called msnbc
it employs such luminaries as joy reid
but this is not from joy reid's show
this is from morning joe
with joe scarborough and i guess the
other lady is his wife and it's a whole
bunch of leftists just lying about
everything all the time it's just boring
nonsense whatever
however once in a blue moon something
happens where you see these people
actually realize that it's their own
policies that are destroying their own
cities and it's quite extraordinary to
watch them realize it in real time so
here's a panel there's about 87 talking
heads and they're talking about san
francisco and crime and they're slowly
it's like their brains are turning on
they're slowly realizing that these
cities like san francisco and portland
are run by leftists just like them
so joe while some of these images of
course are shocking to look at they're
absolutely not surprising to anyone who
lives in san francisco given what's
happened in the last few years there
which is the district attorney has
signaled there we're just not going to
prosecute property crimes we're going to
do it at a much lower rate than it's
ever been done in fact it will be a
misdemeanor if you steal less than 950
that was a proposition of referendum
that passed in that city all the signals
and it's not just san francisco but it's
what we're talking about here are that
if you want to go and steal stuff we're
going to sit back and let it happen or
at least we're not going to prosecute
you after we catch you
well i mean it's in san francisco and by
the way
i'm not sure what the mayor of san
francisco is talking about we must stop
this
it's been happening for a couple of
years now we
a good friend of ours went into a
louboutin store to get a pair of sweats
about 10 people stormed into the store
pulled out guns and just started piling
stuff into suitcases it's been san
francisco is out of control portland is
out of control and and you look
important you're right really
laws have consequences
and and
and
i don't know
who sent the memo out
that like over the last couple years was
a dawning of the age of aquarius
and we actually didn't have to worry
about crime and punishment but we do
we do and when you don't these are the
consequences
i mean
just spectacular
tell me that's not just spectacular
all of those little tv box leftists
including although he didn't say
anything in that segment that's chief
race huckster al sharpton uh all of them
suddenly realizing that it's
progressives who run portland it's
progressives who run san francisco it's
progressives who run new york it's
progressives who run la
it's progressives who run seattle and
that it's the mayors and it's the da's
and all of these things and you can sort
of see it and sort of they don't know
exactly what to say and then joe and my
god did you hear that guys joe has a
friend who went to buy louboutin am i
pronouncing it correctly lou baton who
went to buy louboutin sweats which just
sounded expensive so while we were
playing the clip i asked the guys to
google it louboutin sweatpants cost
twenty three hundred bucks
no conservative is spending twenty three
hundred dollars on sweatpants okay that
is obviously he's a lefty his friends
are lefties they love money and they
love making other people feel guilty
about money while they hoard money for
themselves and buy twenty three hundred
dollar sweatpants poor joe with the
friend with my friend couldn't get to do
it
i'm literally wearing the same pair of
sweatpants i've had for like five years
right now they're they're ratty and
they're old and i love them i love them
anyway i don't like these people very
much in case you can't tell speaking of
people i don't like and related to the
story of sort of the ridiculousness of
leftism what these people do like
parasites they go to places and they
destroy cities nancy pelosi
uh who of course is one of the most
powerful congresswomen in america i'm
fairly certain she's also an alcoholic
she um
she just bought a 25
million dollar house
in florida now do we have an image of
the house there's the house that's
nancy's new house and my god what is all
that blue stuff
right beyond her house it looks sort of
wet
um it looks wavy is that water and i
thought that the water was rising and
sea levels were coming you'd have to be
a psychopath to buy a 25 million dollar
house if you were a good progressive
lefty who goes to climate conferences
and tells people not to
you know drive their cars while you fly
there in private jets etc etc
but she's a hypocrite of course and
she's moving to florida where of course
she would tell you that ron desantis has
mismanaged covid but she's going even
though she's 8 000 years old and
obviously in a high-risk group because
of kovid but she knows it's all [ __ ]
this is what these people endlessly do
so anyway this picture leaked oh and i
should also address it's like where did
this woman get 25 million dollars i mean
i get it through poli this is what
politics is right like you're just
connected to all of these people her
husband is super rich is he what was he
he's like a finance guy or something
yeah so and they're loosely somehow
isn't she like the second cousin 14
times removed from gavin newsom or
something like he's a traitor or
something like that anyway
it's like she's got 25 million dollars
for a home this woman should not be
governing over you she's governing over
you idiots in san francisco that's what
she's actually doing um but anyway david
sacks my buddy from craft ventures who
was one of our investors in locals from
the all in podcast uh he had a great
tweet on this because i just think this
is just so perfect uh he tweeted out i
have a pitch for a sitcom a progressive
speaker of the house using insider
trading gains retires to a rich florida
community filled with the very people
she used to demonize and moralize
against including a former president and
tolf got top golf pro high jinks ensues
too unrealistic then he went on to say
pilot episode in order to add staff
quarters onto her mansion former speaker
must battle byzantine permitting process
thereby drawing the ire of local
bartender and environmental leader alexa
obasado caballo i want to show you some
of the other houses of some of these
rich people because they're very
concerned
about rising sea water right and it's
coming you're going to drown you're
going to be sitting in your hot tub
drinking your champagne and the water's
going to get you here's barack obama's
house oh there we go there's barack he
moved to martha's vineyard i think
that's about a 12 million dollar house
right off
all of that blue stuff the water and you
can see it could just flow over and it
could you know just take michelle out to
sea but i guess barack doesn't care
about that and then there's that bill
gates guy who's very excited to inject
all of your children with experimental
drugs well here's his house up in
seattle how much is that house it was
something like 70 million bucks or
something like that yeah that doesn't
even matter but bill why would you have
a dock there man i mean that dock could
overflow with water and be pushed onto
your house and break the windows
oh hypocrisy you
know no bounds do you